de la légende encore voici un autre tube
de l'été qui reviennent pour la dernière
fois nous évoquerons bien sûr ceux
d'aujourd'hui
mais d'abord immersion dans les années
90 avec une série en à lambada saga
africa macarena vous pouvez vous levez
vous défouler bien sûr avec nicolas
lemarignier mathias second égale prouve
souvenez-vous des années 90 et des 3 ar
lambada saga africa et macarena la
lambada est né en amérique du sud
au départ c'est une chanson interprétée
par un groupe bolivien repéré sur place
en 89 par deux producteurs français dont
l'avion qui les ramène vers la france
ils rencontrent nicolas hulot des deux
producteurs du faveur peut vous laisser
ce disque là qu'on a ramené écoutez vous
allez voir c'est génial et à ce moment
là
nicolas hulot donne ce disque à
dominique cantien qui dirige les
variétés les divertissements sur une
très grande chaîne française elle dit
mais c'est incroyable ça va être le tube
de l'été
porté par une campagne télévisée sans
précédent le titre est l'un des plus
grands tubes de l'été de toute
l'histoire de la chanson un million sept
cent trente cinq mille exemplaires
vendus
les étés suivants la lambada fait des
petits à commencer par saga africa en 91
pour ses débuts dans la chanson yannick
noah fait sensation en interprétant son
tube après la victoire des tennismen
français en finale de la coupe davis
non
mais une bonne danse de l'été c'est
avant tout une bonne chorégraphie et un
côté initiatique
on a envie d'apprendre la danse une fois
qu'on a la maîtrise on l'apprend aux
autres mais on est surtout très content
de bondir sur la piste dès qu'on entend
la macarena
et justement les créateurs de la
macarena ont tout compris étaient 96 les
parents le raconte comment une fille se
déhanche pour attirer les garçons dans
son lit mais ce que le public a retenu
c'est ça ces mouvements ont été inventés
par la célèbre chorégraphe mia frye et
ont largement contribué au succès
planétaire de la chanson 11 millions de
disques vendus et cet été 2008 alors qu
est-ce qui cartonne sur les plages et
dans les boîtes dans les clubs
c'est un dj français laurent wolf qui
fait bouger les vacanciers
un gros
tout
on te plaît
c'est
gillies et kablan beaucoup plus zen il y
à william baldé
son rayon de soleil s'écoute en boucle
sur les plages finalement comment un
artiste crétine un tube
l'interprète peu importe pour qu'une
chanson soit réussie ce qui est très
important c'est la chanson c'est la
sonorité
il faut beaucoup d'insolence besoin de
chanson pour danser pendant l'été parce
que c'est la saison de la drague et
beaucoup d'inconscience
l'important c'est que la chanson laisse
des souvenirs ensoleillés plein la tête
c'est finalement ça la recette d'un tube
de l'été